très vite et politique ce matin c'est
clément bonne bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale
bonjour stéphane bern et bonjour orione
stéphane qui dirige le bureau parisien
du journal ouest france
on commence clément bonne avec cette
agression dont a été victime emmanuel
mâcon président de la république il ya
donc été giflée l'autre jour dans la
drôme condamnation unanime de l'ensemble
de la classe politique pour dire que
cette agression est inacceptable
condamnation salutaire condamnation
nécessaire mais l'image elle a fait le
tour de l'europe voire le tour du monde
est-ce qu'il ya quand même un risque
d'affaiblissement de l'image de la
france avec ce genre d'image non je
crois pas parce que malheureusement
c'est un acte évidemment le très grave
qu'il ne faut surtout pas relativiser
banalisée dans la violence qu'ils
expriment
mais qui s'est produit à d'autres
endroits en europe je pense à l'ancien
premier serait spagnol monsieur rares
ory qui avait été l'objet d'agressions
aussi et donc ce n'est pas un
affaiblissement l'image de la france
c'est un acte graf qui a été condamnée
d'ailleurs au delà de nos frontières par
un stand de responsables politiques
européens par des messages publics ou
privés tant mieux on avait besoin je
crois de cette unanimité en france que
ce soutien large et puis ça montre aussi
par cette unanimité que la france sait
réagir se ressaisir que la république se
défend quand elle est attaquée à travers
le visage à travers la figure du
président de la république donc je crois
pas le bio soit un affaiblissement c'est
la façon dont on réagit qui détermine
image de la france et cette réaction je
peux le dire a été bonne a été
républicain a été unanime vous avez
quand même un oeil sur la presse
étrangère puis vous avez réseau
diplomatique est ce que les ambassadeurs
et consuls où vous font part de réaction
ou de deux cas un peu particulier par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé ou ce que
c'est
non il ya aussi là des messages de tous
partis politiques prises deux
responsables politiques chefs de partis
ministre chef de gouvernement qui ont
exprimé auprès de la république
jean-yves le drian à moi le soutien ce
qui me concerne notamment les
responsables européens à la france
auprès de la république à notre
gouvernement
et ça serait quand même année mois sacré
un émoi bien sûr parce qu'on voit
partout il ya une violence politique et
il faut aussi que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités dans l'expression
publique parce que juif le quelques
scènes que nous avons vécue ne vient pas
de nulle part
c'est parce qu'il ya un climat pas qu'en
france malheureusement dans les milieux
politiques aujourd'hui dans le monde
politique dans le débat public à travers
les réseaux sociaux à travers les
invectives à travers les insultes par
l'anonymat parfois qui crée ce climat on
l'a vu chez nous ces derniers jours
malheureusement au delà de la gifle que
le préau la république a subi et on le
voit dans toutes les grandes démocraties
il faut que je crois en soit très
vigilant parce que c'est un acte on
pourrait dire ça n'est qu'une gifle mais
c'est une forte expression de violence
dans un contexte violences verbales
physiques qui se libèrent
malheureusement et donc être républicain
entre démocrates
c'est aussi non seulement condamner bien
sûr tant mieux cela a été fait par tous
on a vu gérard larcher pour le sénat ici
mais ce loi benoît cité agir à modérées
dans nos propos à être juste nos
expressions à ne pas céder à des
violences de tous types dans l'excès
dans la parole parce que c'est cela qui
crée un processus aussi on va parler de
la crise sanitaire et du déconfinement
on va essayer d'y voir plus clair avec
vous alors on a beaucoup parlé de la
réouverture des salles des restaurants
tiens on va voir avec vous comment ça se
passe au niveau européen sur la
circulation des personnes à l'intérieur
de l'espace européen et pour les
étrangers qui veulent venir en europe
est ce qu'aujourd'hui les citoyens
européens vaccinées peuvent venir en
france sans aucun problème s'entassent
négatif oui il ya deux étapes
importantes et puis on ajustera le
dispositif le 9 juin
hier c'était une réouverture de nos vies
sociales un peu plus grande mais c'était
aussi un moment important on prépare la
saison touristique de réouverture de nos
frontières avec prudence et en
différenciant fonction bien sûr la
situation sanitaire des pays pour
l'europe c'est à dire pour les pays de
l'union européenne
on a classé tous nos voisins en pays
vert c'est l'autre cas d'ailleurs aussi
pour sept pays qui ne sont pas européens
pays vers ça veut dire en effet si vous
êtes vacciné
vous pouvez rentrer en france sans autre
formalité on vérifie évidemment de
vaccins et puis on vérifie si vous
n'avez pas de vaccin vous pouvez venir
quand même que vous avez un test négatif
pcr ou antigénique de moins de 60 w dire
qu'il ya des facilités quand même pour
les gens qui sont vaccinés à ce qu à
défaut de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire vous n'êtes pas en train de
la rendre nécessaire non alors je veux
très clair chacun à ce choix il ya
toujours une alternative aux vaccins
néanmoins le vaccin c'est une protection
donc le pas le rendre obligatoire ne
veut pas dire renier les bénéfices du
vaccin et oui j'encourage par ailleurs
parce que ça facilite les choses
on le voit mais pas parce que on cherche
à recréer des obligations par la porte
de derrière
parce que le vaccin est une vraie
protection c'est pour cela que on le
prend en compte mais qu'on peut faire
des tests aussi j'insiste parce que
cette question se pose parfois pour être
très concret les vaccins dont on parle
ce sont les vaccins approuvés
homologuée par l' agence européenne des
médicaments les seuls vaccins qu'on
utilise en france évidemment c'est à
dire que les quatre vaccins
aujourd'hui disponible en contre et non
pas le vaccin grâce à sa marque zara
russe pas le vaccin chinois qui ne sont
pas à ce stade ont reconnu par les
autorités sanitaires
jekel il fait concrètement quelle
différence il ya entre le pass
sanitaires à la française et le
certificat vert numérique européen ce
sont deux super cadre juridique
différent mais les concrètement ces jeux
lançait le même outil dire si vous avez
un code qr dans votre téléphone sur une
feuille de papier parce que vous êtes
vacciné ou puisque j'avais fait un test
c'est cela aussi le support européen le
certificat européen c'est la même chose
pour aller voir un match de foot dans
les prochaines semaines s'il ya plus de
1000 personnes ou pour voyager en europe
simplement pour être précis et une
deuxième date qui est très important
c'est le 1er juillet est ce que c'est le
1er juillet que ce code sera reconnu à
harmoniser partout en europe mais y'a
pas besoin d'eux
2 aurait pas que alors pour être là
aussi très concret parce que c'est des
choses de la vie quotidienne pour ce qui
peut-être vous avais une vaccination
vous avez un code de votre téléphone
aujourd'hui vous faites trop technique
mais il n'est pas au format harmonisé
européen parce qu'on a été un peu en
avance sur beaucoup de nos voisins et
sur le règlement européen
le règlement européen a été votée hier
par le parlement européen donc ça
commence et dans le cours du mois de
juin automatiquement sur votre
application si vous avez ça dans tous
antico vide le code va se transformer
vous ne le verrez sur l'autre même pas
mais vous n'avez pas à jongler c'est
tout l'intérêt du dispositif entre
différents bout de papier où différents
codes pour voyager en europe
alors vous avez parlé des pays vers donc
tous les pays de l'union européenne plus
sept pays qui ne le sont pas il ya aussi
des pays que vous avez classé en orange
n'étaient que vous avez classé en rouge
concrètement quels sont les critères qui
ont permis de classer ces pays et qu'est
ce que ça implique pour pour les gens
alors pour les pays vert juste pour
expliquer les critères c'est évidemment
sont évidemment les critères sanitaires
d'incidence de dépistage qui ont été
définies au niveau européen et donc on a
appliqué à négocier puis appliquer ces
critères européens pour définir la liste
verte et européens et 17 pays israël
liban par exemple qui sont en très bonne
situation sanitaire pour les autres pays
c'est parce que la situation sanitaire
est moins bonne que l'on les classes en
orange ou en rouge c'est à dire parce
que le taux d'incidence de diffusion du
virus est plus élevé et où qu'il ya
beaucoup de variantes prend l'exemple du
royaume-uni bonne situation sanitaire
l'ensemble c'est vrai mes inquiétudes
sur la diffusion du variant 10 indiens
et donc on a classé à ce stade le
royaume uni orange pays orange ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que la
circulation est possible si vous êtes
vacciné vous devez quand même faire un
test on rajoute cette précaution et si
vous n'êtes pas vacciné
vous devez évidemment faire un test si
vous voulez rentrer en france mais en
plus il faut pour le moment justifier de
ce qu'on appelle un motif impérieux
il faut une bonne raison pour rentrer
sur le territoire je précise ça vaut
pour tous les cas être ressortissant
français c'est un motif impérieux pour
entrer sur le territoire toujours vous
n'avez pas besoin d'autres
justifications que vous êtes citoyen
français vous faire rentrer en france
pour six vous n'allez un pays oranje
d'un pull rouge en visant les tests
nécessaires ou la quarantaine nécessaire
les pays rouge ce sont les pays où la
situation sanitaire est l'âme
bonne très dégradé généralement des pays
où le variant les variants circule
beaucoup le brésil lundi à 16 pays
aujourd'hui dans cette liste et là vous
avez des motifs impérieux encore plus
strict pour entrer sur le territoire
un test à l'embarquement un test à
l'arrivée et une quarantaine qu'on
surveille aussi est-ce que c'est un
classement jusqu'à amener à évoluer
à quelle rapidité on n'a pas changé ces
pays williams n'a pas fixé de délai donc
ça s'applique toujours jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
et s'il ya une information nouvelle ont
réagi vite vous avez des inquiétudes sur
certains pays d'ores et déjà vous avez
vu qu'à chaque e sur la liste des
variantes à commencer par quatre pays et
puis on a élargi la liste jusqu'à 16
aujourd'hui ça peut s'allonger parce que
c'est la contrepartie si je puis dire
on rouvre on n'est pas fou on veut du
tourisme mais on veut d'abord la santé
et donc on nous a reproché d'ailleurs
parfois d'être trop laxiste sur les
frontières les mêmes nous disent
aujourd'hui sauver le secteur
touristique
ils ont raison le souvent les dents en
sauvant l'ouvrant mais pas n'importe
comment et pas n'importe quelle grippe
ou une condition donc ces listes peuvent
évoluer
bien sûr il n'y a pas de régularité dans
l'ajustement est ce que une fois ci une
situation sony prévalu juste en harmonie
avec tous les pays européens la france
peut-elle même décidé de classer un bond
est simple nous mêmes parce que les
procédures open je le regrette sont
encore un peu lentes mais on a on
progresse on à harmoniser les critères
pour la liste verte par exemple et on a
désormais par le centre européen qui
contrôlent l'épidémie des critères pour
définir aussi les pays acp variant mais
la décision ensuite et national et d'ici
le 30 juin
c'est à dire d'ici la mise en place du
poste sanitaire je pense qu'on regardera
pas si elle évoluera mais on regardera
de nouveau ses listes pour voir si on
bouge
certains pays d'une catégorie à l'autre
on vous dit en vue du tourisme mais
d'avoir la santé et vous avez évoqué a
manqué un point clé c'est celui de
quarantaine
est ce que la france améliore son
dispositif de quarantaine est ce qu'on
va faire des quarantaines vraiment
street
est-ce qu'on va continuer à avoir une
gestion un peu je peux dire laxiste mais
d'abord pourquoi il ya parfois ce
sentiment qui est quand même très souple
d'abord on a un cadre juridique y
compris indiqué par le conseil concept
gagnant avec le fait que c'est un point
clé le faire devront gérer corrélation
quarantaine et nature assez sévère jauge
explique nous pour envoyer ces débats
parce que liv à quelles rubriques très
strictes qui nous a obligé c'est normal
c'est une restriction de liberté très
forte à être très précis dans le ciblage
de la quarantaine on le fait et ça
fonctionne bien si ça fonctionne
aujourd'hui de bruit pour les pays acp
variant évidemment le fait sur nombre de
pays ciblés c'est un dispositif très
lourd vous avez quand vous venez de
l'inde ou du brésil d'abord on vérifie à
l'embarquement
la raison de venir ça limite beaucoup
les flux il ya beaucoup moins de vols
quand vous arrivez parce que vous êtes
français par exemple que vous avez une
juste raison de revenir et bien la
quarantaine est appliquée vérifier vous
avez un arrêté préfectoral qui vous
impose et ses contrôles et sanctionner
de rester chez vous vous avez des appels
ou des visites des forces de l'ordre qui
peuvent venir pas rentrer dans votre
appartement mais vérifier que c'est
appliquer une sanction qui dépasse les
1000 euros
si vous ne respectez pas cette
quarantaine donc oui ceux disponibles
aujourd'hui elle est vraiment au permis
pour les pays acp variant on a pour les
pires rouge
on a ce dispositif il est vérifié que
pour les pays rouges que pour les pays
rouges la quarantaine est obligatoire
contrôlé vérifié pour le pays rouges et
seulement pour les pays rouges à ce
stade on va parler de la question des
tests et s ils sont gratuits en france
mais c'est loin d'être le cas dans les
autres pays
si on part en vacances dans un autre
pays l'européenne qu'on est pas vaccinés
on a donc besoin d'un test pour revenir
est ce que pour les français ce texte
sera gratuit à l'étranger où ils devront
payer le test au tarif du pays en
question je me permets de rappeler quand
même parce que
et beaucoup de débats sur la gestion de
cette crise ça n'est pas rien à voir les
tests gratuits et c'est très rare même
en europe
on n'est que deux pays à le faire la
france et le danemark c'est un geste de
solidarité puisque ça coûte quelque
chose de faire les tests sécurité
sociale qu'il prend en charge la
solidarité nationale c'est très
important je le rappelle c'est pas le
cas chez nos voisins alors quand vous
êtes français que vous allez l'étranger
vous êtes soumis au dispositif du pays
étrangers en grèce en espagne c'est
payant et c'est parfois assez cher 150
euros en moyenne en europe
vous avez la possibilité d'être
remboursés en partie forfaitairement par
l'assurance maladie quand vous revenez
en france où il faut faire une petite
démarche une déclaration en partie ce
qu'on vient 50 euros c'est 50 euros
c'est forfaitaire ça couvre le prix dans
certains pays pas tous dans tous les
pays mais voilà on a une solidarité
nationale qui s'exprime chez nous on a
un geste de solidarité supplémentaire
pour nos ressortissants
quand ils vont à l'étranger mais c'est
pas intégral en effet vous souhaitiez un
tarif harmonisé vous vous parliez un
moment d'un tarif harmonisé est ce que
ça sera le cas ou non respect d'un coup
deux pays n'ont pas rennes ont pas voulu
abaisser trop fortement même rendre
gratuits les tests dans le passé
sanitaire européen il ya un principe
mais c'est un principe un peu général
qui dit l'était doivent être des tests
parlons doivent être à un prix abordable
certains pays je veux pas rentrer dans
trop de nuances ou de complexité mais
différencie en fonction de la rapidité
du test pour nous on a un dispositif
gratuit j'en suis très fier je pense que
ça nous protège et c'est bien pour les
français à l'étranger c'est pas le cas
mais on les aide un peu est-ce que c'est
aussi bien pour les étrangers qui
viennent passer leurs vacances en france
aso ça veut dire que la france fait
raelert est de retour pour leur pays
d'origine
oui pour l'instant c'est gratuit
effectivement france je souhaite que ça
le reste parce que je crois ça parait il
faut expliquer ça paraît une générosité
peut-être excessive mais d'abord c'est
très compliqué si on commence à
différencier parce qu'on ne demande pas
beaucoup d'informations qui ont fait un
test on veut justement pour les raisons
sanitaires que ce dispositif soit facile
rapide gratuit accessible et donc si
qu'on commençait à différencier vous
ralentissez aussi pour les français
et puis ici il ya des gens on le
souhaite que le maximum de personnes
dans des conditions surviennent en
france sept étaient de l'étranger
s'il reste trois ou quatre semaines sur
notre territoire parce qu'ils louent un
gîte rural parce que ils sont à l'hôtel
etc
on a quand même plutôt envie qu'eux ils
fassent des tests dans notre intérêt
collectif et qui est pas en quelques
sortes de comportements de passager
clandestin on dira c'est un peu cher
quand je le fais pas pourquoi l'on je
crois que le dispositif simple
accessible
c'est notre intérêt collectif on va
parler du g7
oui je me laissais de ce cette fin de
semaine il sera question entre autres
sujets des vaccins est ce que c'est ce
g7 va permettre va permettre d'acter la
levée des brevets sur les vaccins contre
locaux vides alors là aussi je veux être
prêt si j'espère que ce g7 il va faire
avancer l'idée acolytes et l'action du
vaccin comme bien public mondial
j'insiste sur cette formule c'est pas un
slogan bien public mondial ça venir un
vaccin accessible à tous même dans les
pays où il n'ya pas de capacités de
production il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'argent et un système de santé fragile
en afrique en particulier et je sais ce
que concrètement emmanuel macron lors de
sa jeunesse elle va demander la levée
des ports alors emmanuel macron il a dit
qu'il était favorable levée des brevets
le moment venu j'insiste pourquoi c'est
pas le principe c'est le moment d'en
parler absolument mais le principe il va
discuter à l'om sait il va discuter et
dans les mois qui viennent et le prirent
la fuite il a déjà dit qu était un
déplacement en afrique du sud qui le
pour faire encore plus simple levée des
brevets pourquoi pas bien sûr mais il a
dit la propriété intellectuelle c'est sa
compagne ne doit jamais être un obstacle
à l'accès aux brevets je veux dire c'est
qu'à court terme ce n'est pas le blocage
le blocage s'est tout simplement l'accès
au vaccin vous levez le brevet
aujourd'hui cet après midi vous n'aurez
pas de vaccin demain matin en afrique
c'est ça qu'il faut bien faire
comprendre et donc l'urgence je les dis
ici au sénat y ait encore quelques jours
l'urgence c'est de lever toutes les
restrictions d'export les américains en
avaient encore ces derniers jours qu'il
l'élève
c'est ça le plus important et c'est ça
le message d'urgence que nous passerons
g7 lever les interdictions d'export
l'europe exporte les etats-unis non le
royaume uni non
faisons le 2 à court terme et ça n'est
pas de la charité il faut faire des dons
de doses de vaccin en temps une fois
présence déjà ce que fait la france
ce qu'a fait l'europe ce qu'on l'appelle
kovac c'est à dire la solidarité
internationale est un mécanisme dont
deux doses de vaccin
c'est l'europe qui le finance
massivement aujourd'hui joe biden a
annoncé à la veille de son
déplacement en europe et pour le g7
qu'ils commenceraient donné 12 tant
mieux mais c'est ça l'urgence
et puis oui après c'est l'étape suivante
vous devez faire ce qu'on appelle des
transferts de technologie peut-être des
dispositifs de licence obligatoire
c'est-à-dire que les laboratoires ça
c'est vrai c'est très important ne
puisse pas bloqué mais là on est dans le
plus long terme en feu mais ça prend
quelques semaines ou quelques mois
et donc la levée des brevets très bien
ça viendra il faut commencer à discuter
maintenant ça aura effet dans 6 à 9 mois
parce que ça s'organise et c'est donc
l'urgence le volet l'interdiction export
de long les doses augmentons les
capacités de production en afrique on a
lancé dans la vie du président un projet
soutenu par la france pour produire sur
place et ensuite on peut commencer à
discuter maintenant ça sera utile dans
quelques mois
levée des brevets pourquoi pas puisqu'on
parle du g7 j'ai un accord des ministres
des finances du g7 sur un taux minimum
mondial sur les sociétés de 15% alors
c'est un accord historique
mais c'est qu'un premier pas il doit
être validée déjà par jay 7 après par le
g20 l'accord est encore loin d'être
conclu et surtout est-ce que vous pensez
que ça sera acceptée par l'ensemble des
pays de l'union européenne oui je le
crois et je veux dire aussi là dessus
c'était une bataille française et
européenne faut pas se tromper là dessus
parce que nos amis américains
on peut voler au secours de la victoire
sousse et c'est celui qui a mis le
verrou sur la porte qui quand ils le
ouvre le verrou dit j'ai ouvert la porte
bon les américains s'étaient pas la
faute de monsieur by day c'était son
prédécesseur ils ont bloqué dans tous
les formats je sais que ces dlc l'idée
même d'une taxation des entreprises
numériques d'une taxation minimale
pendant quatre ans nous avons été tout
seul puis avec l'allemagne avec d'autres
pays européens
on y arrive tant mieux j'ai aucun doute
sur le fait que ce sera confirmé au g7
des chefs d'état et de gouvernement le
g20 je crois le soutiendra sans problème
et l' ocde j'espère arrivera cette année
cet été par don à un accord au sein de
l'union européenne on le sait il faut
pas se cacher les choses les règles
fiscales sont décidées à l'unanimité il
ya des pays je pense à l'irlande en
particulier qui sont encore au style
donc un risque de blocage
moi je crois qu'on surmontera ce risque
de blocage et je le dis très sincèrement
en plus une sympathie personnelle j'ai
habité pour l'irlande on ne peut pas
accepter en tant qu'européens que un
blocage demeure sur les sujets aussi
sensibles que l'opinion publique à juste
titre ne peut pas comprendre que
l'administration américaine alors qu'on
a tant lutté pour amener les américains
sur notre position a enfin accepté que
probablement plus 100 pays l ocde
accepteront ça n'est pas raisonnable ça
n'est pas acceptable et de l'autre côté
vous avez un certain nombre de députés
européens qui trouvent que t'inspire
sens et pas assez j'exagère c1 qu ils
ont un seul côté je me suis mis moi
c'est amusant connaissent en général on
le dit plutôt content avec ce trop et je
rappelle qu'en france même en le
baissant un petit peu pour justement
converger vers les grandes économies
européennes
on sera à 25% donc nous on n'a aucun
problème à ce que le taux il soit 21 %
on avait dit qu'on était d'accord bruno
le maire l'avait exprimé et même jusqu'à
25 pourquoi pas nous on n'a pas de
problème avec ça ça ne nous handicape
rappaz est au contraire ça sera plutôt
une sorte de convergence vers notre
position donc c'est un peu je toujours
un peu surpris et c'est un peu saugrenue
que on disait la france vous êtes
maintenant pour le dumping fiscal nous
qui nous sommes battus pour cette
convergence internationale cette justice
fiscale internationale je crois que pour
reprendre toutes les déclarations du
prendre la république le plus le
discours de la sorbonne ya quatre ans
maintenant et on nous dit toujours qu'on
taxe trop alors voyez il faut un peu de
cohérence et un peu de raison dans tout
cela
le taux de 15% ont ni favorable si ça
peut trouver le consensus international
si c'est un peu plus tant mieux on va
parler d'immigration on va parler de ce
qui se passe au danemark qui a renforcé
encore sa législation anti immigration
on était déjà très dur les ont voté une
loi qui permet de traiter hors d'europe
les demandes d'asile qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette loi je pense que c'est
dangereux
je pense que c'est dangereux parce que
là aussi il faut remettre un peu de
clarté dans le débat qu'on lutte contre
l'immigration illégale
très bien qu'on lutte contre les trafics
les passeurs qu'on dise la france le
fait je souhaite qu'on le fasse de
manière européenne
il ya des gens qui ont le droit de venir
sur notre territoire il ya des gens qui
n'ont pas le droit de venir sur le
territoire c'est nous qui choisissons et
maîtrisant nos frontières c'est normal
j'ai aucun problème avec ça en revanche
le droit d'asile
c'est de ça qu'on parle d'hier dire des
gens qui ont droit à l'asie
en france est protégé par la
constitution et dans la plupart des pays
européens réfugiés qui fuient la guerre
qui fut des persécutions politiques
c'est ça d'asile qu'on leur dise on ne
regardera pas votre demande et on
externalise c'est le terme pudique pour
dire vous exclus on ne vous accueillent
plus et on va faire traiter
honnêtement je sais pas comment ça
marcherait même votre demande d'asile
votre accueil entre guillemets par un
pays qui a plus de dix mille kilomètres
avec lequel vous n'avez aucun lien je ne
sais pas dans quelles conditions
ça se ferait selon par le rwanda bon je
pense que d'abord c'est une chimère
ne faisons pas croire qu'il ya des
solutions et qu'on peut créer
est-ce que c'est acceptable sur le plan
humain et même sur le plan si je puis
dire ainsi de l'efficacité de créer des
camps de migrants qui ont droit à
l'asile potentiellement dans des pays
qui sont en afrique qui sont déjà en
difficulté
honnêtement je crois que ça ce ne sont
pas les valeurs européennes et je crois
d'ailleurs que c'est une fausse piste
c'est une illusion parce que nous faire
ne faisons pas croire aux européens que
c'est en afrique dans d'autres pays que
les pays d'origine que on va faire
traiter
si je puis dire les demandes d'asile
sont pas valeurs européennes est ce que
l'union européenne va réagir l'union
européenne a déjà réagi la commission
européenne mission mais ces inquiétudes
on va regarder les procédures mais je
veux pas judiciariser tous les sujets ou
dire on va faire ça peut aller jusqu'aux
bas la commission européenne va regarder
c'est conforme aux engagements
internationaux que nous avons en tant
qu'européens mais c'est un débat
politique je pense que c'est une erreur
politique et je le dis c'est un
gouvernement social démocrate
je viens de la social démocratie
européenne on reçoit des leçons souvent
d'humanité de beaucoup de partis sociaux
démocrates européens
franchement là on a une dérive qui est
très grave un mot pour finir sur
l'immigration avant de parler du brics
et avec stéphane est-ce qu'il faut
revenir sur les accords du touquet c'est
les accords qui régissent la frontière
franco britannique c'est ce que demande
xavier bertrand je ne crois pas je ne
crois pas parce que on ouvrirait à court
terme une grave difficulté y compris
pour la france qu'est ce que ça voudrait
dire ça voudrait dire qu'on aurait une
sorte de bataille navale migratoire en
mer l'accord du touquet ça veut dire que
pour éviter les traversées trop risqué
on traite le sujet migratoires
effectivement en france
en revanche je le dis les britanniques
ne sont pas à la hauteur de leurs
engagements en termes de soutien
financier la france fait un effort qui
je pense humains nécessaires protecteur
pour nous aussi parce que sinon on
aurait encore plus de tentatives de
passage et donc à la fin encore plus de
gens qui viendraient dans les hauts de
france donc c'est une fausse solution de
dire dénonçons les accords et tout sera
réglé
en revanche on doit avoir une
coopération plus stricte avec les
britanniques où ils doivent nous aider
parce qu on le fait aussi dans leur
intérêt a dû gérer la frontière à lutter
contre les trafics à lutter contre
l'immigration illégale qui là pour le
coup je n'ai aucun scrupule aucun état
d'âme avec ça vient créer des dangers
pour la sécurité pour la tranquillité
dans la région de france et on termine
s'imbriquent cette année la transition
et où trouvez-vous nadir les
britanniques sont pas hauteur de leur
engagement dans la matière d'immigration
et sur le bric site comment ça se passe
les accords ont été négociés avec le
pied à pied pendant quatre ans il ya un
certain nombre de points qui ne
respectent pas qu'est ce qu'on fait quel
est le suivi qu'on pouvait assurer par
rapport par rapport à leurs engagements
et comment fait pour les obliger à les
respecter
je dis franchement je suis très inquiet
sur le comportement britannique sur las
le respect de l'accord que nous avons
signé j insiste c'est une question
d'honneur et de respect et de
crédibilité internationale
le royaume uni c'est une grande
démocratie membres du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies qui signent
des accords internationaux et qui
s'associeraient dessus non avec la pêche
leur manifeste ce sujet il ya doute lire
de sucre roux il ya des inquiétudes il
ya deux sujets l'avocat qui lie la pêche
c'est très concret on s'est battu pied à
pied avec comme la république avec
annick girardin amie de la mère pour
défendre l'intérêt des pêcheurs on a un
bon accord à temps il faut qu'il soit
appliqué on va pas laisser refaire le
match
après la série trouve des billets pour
ne pas les respecter et où ils font le
mur et un stand de procédures
administratives
peut-être qu'il y avait des informations
qui n'avait pas été reçue communiqué on
a amélioré les choses encore ces
dernières semaines donc là il ya plus d
excuse il faut donner concrètement
toutes les licences d'accès sur à la mer
pour nos pêcheurs notamment pour ceux
des hauts de france
et puis il ya un sujet qui paraît plus
lointain mais qui nous concerne tous
c'est ce qu'on appelle le
auto cole nord-irlandaise hier comment
on gère la frontière processus de paix
exactement c'est la paix en europe qui
est en jeu et les britanniques ne
peuvent pas nous dire on a un protocole
qui facilite les contrôles mais qui
ancre et quelques-uns forcément des
contrôles disque on a un marché ont
vérifié que ce qui vient du royaume uni
chez nous en termes de protection
sanitaire en termes de règlements
environnementaux fonctionne respecte nos
règles ça c'est normal
donc ils peuvent pas nous dire vous êtes
méchant vous avez créé un protocole
zekri les contrôles c'est le break site
qui a créé une frontières et des
contrôles faut être sérieux
le protocole c'est une réponse pour
essayer de minimiser les problèmes
problème c'est le break side c'est pas
le protocole et donc on attend du
royaume uni parce qu'il a signés parce
que son parlement a ratifié que cet
accord soit intégralement respectés dans
l'accord il est prévu que si ça n'est
pas le cas nous prenions des mesures de
rétorsion droits de douane et autres
j'espère qu'on n'en arrivera pas là mais
si les choses n'avancent pas d'où la
table c'est vos ceintures c'est sur la
table parce que ça c'est dans l'accord
nous on ne demande que le respect des
engagements pris
signée ratifié est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
coups de trafalgar à redouter dans
d'autres domaines par exemple quelques
noms dumping social fiscal
j'espère que non et en tout cas nous
serons je le dis très clairement sans
faiblesse sans naïveté et nous réagirons
est ce que c'est les intérêts de nos
pêcheurs de nos entreprises de nos
consommateurs des citoyens européens et
français spécifiquement que j'ai à
défendre que nous avons à défendre nous
les défendrons sans aucune hésitation
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin
[Musique]